Kathy Griffin baby this is some of the
greatest news it's sort of related to
the election
it's definitely giving us a lot of Joy
Elon Musk has uh suspended Kathy Griffin
from Twitter permanently
he's done it because Kathy Riven
impersonated him a lot of people have
been impersonating Elon Musk if they
have a blue check mark they'll change
their name to Elon Musk put his picture
in pretend to be him so she did that now
she's permanently banned I love it
and the libs are dunking right and
they're saying well yeah so much for
free speech
this is Elon is showing us the way I
published my book last year
with a contrarian take on Free Speech
the whole conservative movement was
saying we need absolute Free Speech all
the time and no guard rails and no
standards and no taboos and I said no no
that's not how Free Speech actually
works the left understands Free Speech a
lot better than we do
it's good to censor certain things it's
good to censor obscenity at least it's
good to censor all sorts of things could
have standards it's good to have a
Common Language you have to have that
that's what politics is and I think that
view has prevailed I think that
the book became a number one National
bestseller and I'm very happy about all
of that I think people are recognizing
The Way Forward is not this
do whatever you want hands on the air
I'm not going to govern I'm not going to
wield power kind of
frivolous libertarianism The Way Forward
is
when conservatives are given power when
we earn power when the people elect us
we have not just the right but the
responsibility to wield that power for
the good more good less bad the libs
wield power for more bad and less good
we need to weld it for more good less
bad certainly very good to kick Kathy
Griffin off Twitter for her fraud
really they could kick her off Twitter
for her terrible comedy but I think it's
also fair to kick her off for committing
fraud right now head on over to
establishtitles.com Knowles established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of Lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in Scotland
okay I had this problem where I thought
I'm just not getting the respect that is
due to me okay people when they come up
to me they'd say hey Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as Lords and Ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com Knowles to get your gifts now
and help support the channel
now speaking of insane women
Anne Hathaway just went on The View
again this is in the final days of the
campaign
to Double Down triple down quadruple
down on the one issue that Democrats
have really focused on this campaign the
quote unquote right to abortion
the devilish product didn't turn 16 this
summer yes the time flies boy so you
wrote this on Instagram quote I am
struck by the fact that the young female
characters in this movie built their
lives and careers in a country then
honored their right to have Choice over
their own reproductive Health see you in
the fight so why did you write that why
was it important to you to you to write
something like that because we're in the
fight yeah we're in the fight every day
we're in the fight every minute and you
mentioned the Devil Wears Prada turning
sweet 16 yeah some 16 year old's life
has been irrevocably changed yeah
because of the current overturning of
Roe v Wade and in this character I
played a young woman who was starting
out her career
and when you are a young woman starting
out your career your reproductive
Destiny matters a great deal of course
my own personal experience with abortion
and I don't think we talk about this
enough abortion can be another word for
mercy
so here she seems to be insinuating that
she's killed one or more of her children
[Music]
out of Mercy
for the children so it could be you know
I mean what what often happens is that
when people find out that their child
has some kind of disorder maybe they're
down syndrome maybe they've got some
kind of problem uh
people today will often just kill their
children and say well we're going to try
again this is why you hear out of
Iceland they say we've eradicated Down
syndrome there's no cure for Down
syndrome so it just means that people
are killing their Down syndrome babies I
don't know exactly what Anne Hathaway
means by this she's using all sorts of
euphemisms but she's saying my own
abortion experience is that abortion can
be an act of mercy and so it's really
weird the fact that she's using
euphemisms I think just proves to you
right there that the she recognizes that
what she's talking about is evil and
will rub people the wrong way and will
be offensive because of how awful it
actually is and the Democrats are using
all sorts of euphemisms now and they're
doing absolutely everything they can to
get around to to to kind of leap over uh
reality the the reality of their of
their policies the reality of their
agenda and the real perception of what
they want from the people and so if the
people aren't going to vote for them
they're gonna they're gonna try to get
around that too I hope they do not
succeed in that but it will be a very
interesting night the first part that
will be interesting are the polls
in those tight races who's going to win
who's going to win New York's 17th
congressional district who's going to
win in Georgia who's going to win in
Arizona but then there's going to be an
entirely
distinct and frankly more interesting
fight that happens which is that if the
races really are close you're going to
see the battle for uh whether or not the
Democrats can properly rig it
to uh let's say let's say Oz is only up
by one or two points can they make up
those ballots in the middle of the night
with undated fraudulent ballots to send
John Federman
to Washington D.C you know the rest of
the show continues now
we got a great pollster on to tell us
what to look for tonight if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]